hey guys sorry for the long silence I
know that's got to be weird considering
I haven't missed a day's uploads since I
started the YouTube channel and many of
you probably already know why but I
wanted to put this video out there as an
informational update for those who don't
check my Facebook or Twitter or social
media channels in general
Daniel kyer of cyndago has passed away
as of last week after an apparent
suicide attempt and if it wasn't obvious
the reason that I haven't been able to
post videos or any of us have been able
to post videos is just because we've
been dealing with it it's been a very
very long week and it hasn't even been a
week yet but it's been a very very long
period of time and if you want to find
out more information about it I will put
links in the description to the Facebook
posts that are relevant about it and I
don't want to go into a lot of details
of like us grieving or us trying to deal
with it I just wanted to let you guys
know once I worked up the courage that I
could I wanted to let you guys know the
why of it like the why the videos aren't
being posted why we're not saying a
whole lot is because we're giving you
know each other time because I'm back in
Cincinnati right now it's being been
very good to be around friends and
family and Ryan and Matt are back in
South Carolina and the whole family is
back home and they're grieving and
they're dealing with it and it's going
to take a lot of time for them to move
on and I just wanted to let you guys
know that I am going to take some time
to process this because this is just a
big loss because Daniel was such an
influence on what we did he was such an
inspiration for what I did he was he was
um he was such a good friend to us and
he was such an important figure in what
we did because we were all living in a
house together and I don't want to get
emotional in this video like
I just want to let you guys know that
we're handling it as best we can we are
reaching out to friends and family we're
reaching out for help and I wanted to
let you guys know that when we come back
we are going to come back you know in a
good way we're gonna come back with
clear heads and we're gonna come back as
strong as we can and when we do come
back I want to do a live stream in
Daniels honor and I want to like
celebrate the life that he lived instead
of no I want to because Daniel was such
a positive influence on a lot of people
and it was a positive influence on me
and so I want to do something to try to
help out the family try to help out us
remembering him and try to help us all
move on from it
and I just want to let you guys know
that we are gonna come back from this
I mean cyndago may have ended but I am
hoping you know I I don't have no
guarantees I am hoping that Ryan and
Matt will want to keep working after
this because I I know that's what Daniel
would want us to do I know Daniel
whatever you know demon see was facing
that he didn't tell us about you know
whatever he was facing I know that he
wouldn't have wanted his problems to
stop us from creating because he was
such a big influence on us making things
and you know he inspired us to expect
better from ourselves you know he was
always the one to like take up the time
to put in extra effort into editing
videos like little tiny my new details
that we would have just overlooked he
always took the time to make sure they
were perfect and especially when it came
to sound but also it came to like the
nuances of editing and he taught us like
his methods and that was it was it's a
it's a big loss from what we're gonna
have but that just means that we have to
try harder when we come back from this
end I can't say for sure when and I
don't know when of like I'm hoping to go
back to LA in about
weeks but I also want to go down to
South Carolina to visit Ryan and Matt
and the family and you know there's a
lot of raw emotions right now and
there's a lot of raw feelings about this
edie there's a lot of unanswered
questions that we all have and were
slowly dealing with but I just want to
let you guys know that we are handling
it and we are trying to move forward as
best we can and we're trying to remember
Daniel for the friend that he was and
the person that he was and I just ask
for patience from you guys during this
time I ask that you guys be mindful and
respectful of the family I know there's
a lot of people out there that are
trying to reach out and trying to show
their support just please give the
family as much time as they need and
don't be intrusive to them and just we
will you know keep you guys up to date
as best I can but I'm really just trying
to take this time to clear my head and
try to finish this strong you know
because it was a long week and I'm like
my heart goes out for the entire family
and I can't imagine you know just based
on what I'm feeling I can't imagine what
they're feeling so anyway I didn't want
to go into all these details if you want
to find more information there's links
in the description and I just wanted to
reassure you guys that markiplier as a
channel will continue I really hope that
Ryan and Matt will want to continue you
know moving forward with me but it's
just gonna take a lot of time it's gonna
take a good bit of time this was a heavy
loss that we all feel and all of you out
there probably feel because in in small
ways that you probably didn't know
Daniel was part of what I did a big part
of what I did and Daniel like he
he did a lot of things that were often
unseen and I just hope that he knew how
much I respected him as a friend anyway
just thank you guys so much for your
support thank you so much for
understanding and we will be back just
send a lot of love you know send a lot
of love towards the other guys there
they really need it now and just thank
you guys so much for being patient
we really appreciate so I will let you
guys know I'll have another update
whenever I can it may be a week I have
no idea just please be patient and you
can check Facebook and Twitter for more
and for more info I'll probably put it
out there first then YouTube but just
thank you guys so much for being there
for us when we needed the most and for
supporting what we've done up until this
point because I want to keep creating I
always want to keep creating I just need
time to get to the point where I can
anyway
thank you guys again and my slide seems
stupid at this point but as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye